[Music]
hello i'm arvin kalzichi i'm a content
developer and instructor with the
wolfram u team here at wolfram research
today we're doing some tech talks which
are interviews with some of our
employees where they tell us about some
fun projects that they've been working
on and how they've been using the
wolfram language today we'll be talking
with john mcloone director of technical
services
and he'll go ahead and tell us about a
project that he's been working on
thank you well um actually the project i
i'm going to be speaking about at the
conference isn't anything to do with our
technical services where we're writing
code for for other customers this is
actually a personal project of my own
where i'm trying to address a piece of
uk health and safety legislation by
creating a website to manage that for
you
right yeah i've certainly done a lot of
uh
hobbyist things in the wolfram language
that had nothing to do with my job
partly because i was doing that before i
started working here but also since i've
started working here i've done a lot of
obvious things
nothing to do with uk regulations or us
regulations however but
right well shall i uh walk you through
what i've been doing
yes please do so let's uh put something
on screen here um so
what i'm trying to do is to address
display screen
equipment regulations so this is a an eu
ruling that uh has its own specific
um
versions in different eu countries and
even
in the uk now that we're not a year
either
and so
basically the idea is that there are
risks associated with using computers
mostly to do with repetitive strain or
posture related injuries and so there's
legislation to protect you it's your
employer's responsibility to make sure
you're using equipment safely and that
it's not just a computer it's keyboards
mouse it's the desk it's the environment
it's how bright the windows are it's all
of that uh
that goes with working with computers
and the idea is you've got to be
evaluated by a competent person and you
could identify risks and then remedia
and so it's fairly straightforward
kind of legislation although with
homeworking ideas of how you evaluate
and what's a competent person get a bit
more complicated as homework rates like
everywhere
racing up in the uk
yeah right that's that's quite a
comprehensive list of things that
they're responsible for
not that that's bad
well and for a company with lots of
employees of course it's becomes a a
chore to not just do these things but
also to audit them and manage them so
that you could prove that you've been
responsible and done the right thing
should you get sued by an employee in
future
right so the idea is to make a website
to manage that and if i uh switch here
to uh open a browser here i can give a
quick glimpse of what it's looking like
so far it's a work in progress so some
of the page design and graphic design
choice is a little bit ugly but the idea
is that i log in
and i have a screen where i can see here
i'm the administrator for this
particular organization that i've got
some
some tasks i'm supposed to be doing i
can have a quick look at those and see
that uh there's some remediation that i
have to do for various employees
and the idea is that as
an organizer for the manager of the
organization i can set up the policies i
can decide whether we're gonna be really
rigorous and uh test things every uh six
months or every 12 months or do it
casually and there's gonna be more
settings about the level of assessment
uh how often you get reminded uh how
accounts get created how we communicate
with the users and a whole bunch of
policies so this is sort of up to the
organization itself and the regulation
is just there you know to provide kind
of you know a safety net for employees
should something go wrong there's not
like
in fact with a lot of these health and
safety things if you don't do anything
you're automatically guilty because you
have not shown your care and attention
and certainly if somebody says that they
were injured through these computers and
you can't demonstrate that you've
checked and fixed their chair or fixed
their the
broken keyboard then you're in trouble
right um so in the end the whole thing
centers around the idea that um
we might set up an environment so we'll
call it uh
my laptop
um i'm test user here at the moment it's
going to be a laptop and it's going to
be situated at home
we'll save that and now we can do an
assessment and the assessment involves
basically answering a whole bunch of
questions
we'll have training to make sure you've
been trained to know what you're
answering and what can make sensible
judgments and the idea is you go through
this and if you say something
non-compliant you're prompted for a bit
more information
about what's gone wrong and it takes you
through all of that right so an
administrator would set this up and then
the
users the employees could come in and
they could set up you know a home
environment a work environment and fill
out one of these forms for each of those
that's right so the employee view is a
little bit simpler they just get the
your profile
the environments
and
and then all the lower tabs are the
manager only tabs so so you have some
sort of permissions dependent menu there
on the left yes that's one of the
challenges is to make sure that you can
only see information you're supposed to
that we're unemployed you can't see
another employee's records but the
manager can you can't see something from
a different organization who might also
be showing the same server and then you
get things like analysis that comes with
this that says okay what's our most
popular problem
uh
what's the progress on tasks and you can
imagine there's all kinds of analytics
that we might have to try and figure out
uh patterns and things that we're doing
systematically wrong
right right
so it's kind of straightforward idea but
of course there's a lot of
workflows of what does what does the
setter do what does the trainer do what
does an employee do
uh what happens if something goes wrong
all of these things have to be worked
through and that's
like all of these business automation
problems is where the complexity sets in
when fundamentally it's a website that
shows you pages and asks you questions
um right and it said in the beginning
that this needs to be reviewed by a
competent person so this is kind of
saying that the employee is competent
enough to judge their own you know
comfort with the keyboard screen you
know lighting environment and everything
which makes sense so there is a um
there's a training uh tab which i
haven't enabled in this version which
you get to watch videos and answer
questions to prove that you've been
paying attention and then when you're
certified as having uh been through the
training and that's of course all logged
and recorded
um then you're allowed to do the
assessment depending on the the
organization's policies they may want to
take risks and say you don't need to be
trained but that's their choice
um i'm not the one who's going to say
that was the right choice which is
exactly so the option yeah the option is
there if people want to actually be
thorough about you know the the language
of the law yeah so cautious companies
will demand the long version of the
training with high pass rates uh
frequently performed and companies don't
want to spend lots of time
human time doing these things might set
those policies a little bit more
liberally
right right that makes sense and
for this analysis tab you have some kind
of pre-loaded uh analyses here are these
things that the administrator could you
know they could add some different sorts
of analyses to view they could only show
certain ones that they're interested in
or is this something that
you were kind of adding by hand yeah at
the moment um
i'm trying to get this thing out of the
door i hope to have it sort of finished
and available as a product that one
could sign up to early in the new year
so i'm trying to avoid too much feature
creep in those directions but
some of the things are things that we
want to make customizable so higher on
the list of customization is the ability
to add questions if you want to check
certain specific things
you can already change how the messaging
works to say whether you want to really
emphatic email saying you must do this
you're going to get fired or whether it
should be much more friendly you can
check several wording so the idea that
you could uh have some extensible um
uh analysis is all potentially further
down the road as well but right now i'm
just trying to pick some i'll probably
end up with about half a dozen key
metrics that one might want to look at
yeah i think that's that seems like a
reasonable number you know
um i do like the idea for sending an
email you know you could have a text box
where you could actually specify the
exact text or you could have a
you know kind of a radio button bar
where you select the severity of the
email
now what i have is if we go into many
organizations
the communications edit email tests um
your assessment due
uh text looks like this and you can type
over that but there are
and those familiar with walking language
you'll recognize these slots markers for
oops i didn't need to close that the
slot marker here for um
things that will be filled in
when the message is generated so these
are template messages rather than the
final thing so and so this is using
slots and you can also use html in your
emails yeah that's right which of course
opens up a um
[Music]
you know a cross-side scripting risk
that one has to mitigate
and i assume you have mitigated it
uh yeah yeah
fairly thoroughly i hope but uh yeah
it comes to security issues you've
thought of everything and done it all
right
yeah i also like that the uh that each
of these email tabs just pops out that's
quite nice instead of loading up a new
form on a new page you just kind of set
all of these at once and go
well
um i should talk a little bit about how
it's made i'm not gonna do the whole of
uh
of
my conference talk but um
what i've done is i've used the um the
new wolfram application server
so that's a lightweight way of serving
up um
waltham language
off websites it's based around docker
and kubernetes so i have a browser
reaches in
accesses wall from application server
and almost everything is done in wolfen
language
so um
the only bit that i've uh
i've taken out separately is the data so
that i can scale data storage well is
backed by a database and there's a tiny
component for sending out um reminder
emails that's done by a walthamscript
side task that just runs a bit of
automatic code reaches into the database
and says who's due for reminders today
and sends those emails out but
everything all the real logic is being
done uh within
waltham application server which isn't
perhaps
what it was designed for um you know if
you're
building um websites you're probably
using other technologies and you would
use walter application server to serve
up some dynamic content or to serve an
api behind the scenes to populate some
parts of the page but actually the way
that i've done it is i'm delivering the
entire html it's constructed in waltham
language and delivered in a single piece
to the
uh to the browser right so people might
think of this as being some you know a
way to add computation to some existing
web page but you're using it to both do
computation and generate the entire web
page and interface and everything that's
right and partly that's because i'm an
and language expert and i'm much more
confident in wolf language than i am in
javascript and nature right right i try
and uh do as much there as possible but
it also means one language for
everything it's the one language is
assembling pages
doing data queries uh applying the
business logic it's all all from
language top to bottom which makes it
actually quite nice to be able to read
through the code without having to say
okay this stuff's in the javascript for
the page and this stuff's in there right
in an sql script so it's all in in one
place it's a real boon not to have to
move back and forth you know
when you're updating editing or just you
know writing these things to begin with
and yeah i certainly uh in my experience
would prefer to be writing a web page in
wolfram language versus using javascript
um
there is some bias here but my
experience matches yours in terms of
ease of use there
you get some direct benefits as well of
being able to use things like functional
programming to you know map an
interactive widget like actually if i go
back to the one we had on screen uh
these
these accordions well that's just an
accordion function within uh
my wolf language code so you just do map
accordion down the
field across the list of options so the
actual page generation here was about
three lines of code it's um
the logic is in the um
as in the passing the values when they
come back but
i can't live without mapping i i need to
be able to map all the time
so
you've mentioned a bit about wolfram
applications over there and kind of it's
generally intended use and how you've
used it so how does that differ from
building a page and hosting it just via
kind of the more general wolfram cloud
what's the what's the difference there
yeah um so the wall from cloud is is the
kind of full feature version but it's a
little bit heavyweight i actually
implemented this in in
all format enterprise private cloud
first of all
and as it happened the one of the things
you get with wolfen cloud is a
permission structure so you can deploy
apis with permissions but because i
didn't want to use
um
permissions that were based around an
equivalent of variable id but i needed
to be more organization oriented it's
not really the way the permission
mechanism was set up
so i didn't need that
and i don't need uh wolf notebooks in
the cloud for this it's all html
javascript that's coming back from the
browser so two of the biggest reasons
for going with application server didn't
apply
um
and so so going with enterprise quality
cloud into play so application server is
lighter weight it's easier to install
you can scale it up much more easily
because of its kubernetes docker
background so um should it be an
incredibly successful company when it
launches then fairly quickly in the
matter of kind of minutes the hours i
can spin up more machines and and scale
thing up and then that's that's kind of
much slicker in application server
but it didn't mean i had a few things i
had to build myself the permissions
mechanism i had to
build from scratch
and um
not terribly owners task um
and because i'm not using notebooks i
don't have things like opener view
instead of these accordions so i had to
build some components
using
um xml element
um being the your bridge into
into html code when you're down at the
kind of nuts and bolts level
right but it seems like yeah it seems
like that wouldn't be too bad to
implement and you know based on what you
said about how much code or how little
code rather
this whole page took to generate seems
like that's not too big a deal yeah i
mean i that's a little bit on top of w3.
javascript and
css as well but i'll probably switch
that to um
to a different framework for actual
release but actually there's very little
of that that just gives me the in page
interactivity
everything else is just once you've
wrapped a layer around
a couple of xml elements to describe
something then it's just a
you know equivalence of open and i'm
awake
nice and you mentioned that you had to
kind of build your own permissions it
makes a lot of sense that
if this is going out to private
organizations you don't want something
that's like a wolfram sign in wolfram
specific sign-in for
external organizations so how did you
how did you build up this permissions
environment
kind of from scratch here so there were
a few key components and then the rest
is basically the logic of the site the
html we've talked about already um
actually added all bits of database link
just to make it more convenient for me
because i really love association
and uh and getting back vectors of
values was very confusing so i have a
thin layer that means i get associations
and data sets back
um the authentication is i'm not gonna
go through step by step but um basically
uh you get
uh a session id
from
wall from application server so for free
that times out after 15 minutes which
for my application is is all i need so i
didn't have to actually implement any
cookie
management at all
you can simply use http headers
to get the the session id
for the application server session
and i'm using that to manage the session
so you ask the password and a username
and password you verify the hashes of
that against the hashes installed in the
database if they match you take the
current session id and you store a hash
of that and after that that's how you
can pair up with the person in so every
page view after that session id comes up
in a cookie
it's looked up in the database uh
against it's hash to say okay or john
mcloone and so the first thing pages do
is they generate the information about
the current user which is then passed in
as a value for the page construction so
the page construction is unless they're
very static things it's always based on
the information of the current user
and
and so
um
probably
if you ignored all the um error checking
the entire permissions mechanism is
probably 30 lines of code it isn't very
much going to say that sounds that
sounds quite clean you know for
something you have to implement
basically from the ground up there aside
from the cookies but
yeah that seems like it would work quite
nicely
oh and then actually i do have a little
bit more which is on top of the who you
are and i've got a kind of mechanism for
um
access control based around
behavior permissions
so there is some logic that says
behavioral permissions like are you
allowed to edit another person
and so if your role is an admin then or
then you get that right if you're a
regular user you don't get that right so
that's really just a little set of uh
logical rules that um
uh that decide are you on are you not
allowed to do a particular thing and
then that's just affected by that right
and that's just stored you know either
in the same association as the user pass
set
user pass hash
or it's stored uh you know some parallel
association that has everybody's
user id hashes and then there yeah
right now the um whether a regular user
is allowed to see the uh the analytics
page is hardcoded but that's one of the
things in phase two i plan to make it so
that the admin the organization can
decide which roles are allowed to do
which activities you can create people
who have special abilities in one area
but less than another right right again
try and avoid feature creep and
get the thing out the door before i add
those extra features
yeah that's uh it's an important thing
to be able to do because
otherwise you just sit there and you
keep adding things adding things out of
things and it's never done so better to
get it out and then you can add these
kind of smaller things as you go the
lessons learned from doing projects for
customers is
the customer will always come back with
more things that they want but you need
to kind of agree some deliveries before
you get started
and
and then visit those ideas they have
later
yeah
you can imagine they can be a little bit
tricky with with customers sometimes
always want some more things and it's
well that's good because we love giving
them things yeah we can do it
you don't lose um
control of the project by
having stage deliveries that everyone
understands
right right it's the um it's the less
fun for my point of view side of
technical services is good project
management i'm more interested in in
writing fun code
yeah
i identify very strongly with that yeah
all right so
you've developed the whole side of
wolfram application server as we've
discussed and
so we talked about a few of these things
so what
i mean of course the the possibly the
main motivator for me was that you know
i knew what to do straight away
but the single language has been quite a
benefit that i found that uh that i
i've i feel frustrated when i'm forced
to go back to javascript now and i'm my
first thought now is well can i put a
wolfram language wrapper around that so
i never have to touch javascript again
uh when i come back
and
the end is to build up all these kind of
reusable components um
that
uh
things that are equivalent to kind of
the widgets that you get in the notebook
but
uh you know you talk about a page at a
much higher level i just say it's got a
navigation
bar wrapper wrapped around a table of uh
input fields that are in accordions and
being able to talk to a page like that
is is nice being able to reuse the
components so that as i do change the
designs they all
pick up those changes and look nice and
consistent together
it's kind of thing you get from web
frameworks
and you wouldn't perhaps you wouldn't
think the wolf language can give you
that same kind of benefit but actually
it works very nicely for that of
building my own library of components
and and then being able to reuse them
without having to constantly negotiate
boilerplate
code
and one of the things about not using
apis as well is that actually i can be
quite careless with data without any
obvious jeopardy to safety because
uh i'm never calling things from
from the html from the client side if
you have a client api you need to make
sure you return only the value that
that
that that api needed to deliver into the
page you don't want to have a whole
bunch of other information what you
might find useful because that's all the
data leak
because my data's all on the server side
because i'm delivering whole complete
pages back to the
to the browser then when i say get your
information on this user i get i hand
out all the information on the user and
it's up to the function that's consuming
it to use the bits that it cares about
so i can be very sloppy about passing
data around within the
server code as long as i never get a
failure where the error message contains
data which i've taken somewhere to make
sure it can never make its way back to
the browser it means that i'm never
having to go back and revisit functions
say oh in this case i need to add
another parameter and another parameter
everything piece of information i need
for a function is nearly always there
um because of this sort of careless
handling and associations where you can
just give all the information and pick
out the key you care
right and about
would be a lot harder to do if you had
not kept this all basically all in the
wolfram language right you had to pass
things back and forth between
different constructs here i think that
would be
less trivial to be so careless about
passing data around right yes yes you
really don't want to return anything
that isn't absolutely required if you're
saying it's the client
because um you know it's hard enough
already to make sure you you don't give
roots for somebody else to find out
about somebody else's private
information and
so you have to be extra careful at
anything that goes back to the client
side
anyway
right
well that's uh it's a very surprising
thing that you're able to build that
entire thing again more or less in the
wolfram language um
quite quickly as well that uh
that you know this is something i've
built entirely kind of after work hours
um
and the occasional
boards sunday afternoon putting some
stuff together
uh over a couple of months or so so um
it's
possible to build out quite a bit quite
quickly because i can take a lot for
granted with the wolfram language even
though i'm barely using computation at
all at the moment
right page is quite basic
which you would think was the main
reason for using it
yeah there's a there's a lot of helpful
stuff in terms of constructs like you
mentioned mapping makes a lot of things
quite trivial uh even if you're not
doing explicit computation
um
and yeah i've seen i've seen some of the
code used to deploy this and
i believe you know it's quite short it
must not have taken too long at all to
to uh write all this stuff up and get it
deployed
well the deployment's particularly easy
because there is a whole
deployment mechanism through service
connect so this is basically how a page
gets deployed
uh within the system and then i have a
short script that
packages together the whole site in
about 20 of these
or 30 of these requests
so
you know here this demo is going i'm
just running on localhost
but all i do is um in my whole site
script for deployment i just uh set the
base url and do a service connect to a
different machine and i'm pushing it
live and i have a
machine here at rel that is running a
early version of this i'm using my
colleagues here at wolf and research
europe as guinea pigs to debug the site
before i uh i let outside people
make use of it yeah kill two birds with
one stone there
and then that deployment is even more
yeah surprisingly simple than i imagined
after having looked at the code to
generate the website itself
yeah well i mean if you look at the
actual website code let's get it on
screen here for a moment i happen to
have
it open
um you know this is
i happen to have one screen here this is
the the navigation bar down the left
hand side and you can see it i'm
mostly dealing with at a pretty high
level it's a bunch of navigation buttons
that have permissions about who's
allowed to see that particular button
so the uh the reason why you didn't see
trading was currently it's set to have
only the super user having permissions
to view the trading button because it's
still quite half built
um
and
manage employees button is only visible
if you have view other rights and so on
but that's that's the page construction
for the the the main wrapper that goes
around every single page you know it's
almost nothing once you've built the
components
at the higher level
yeah
all right thanks so much john for
telling us about this website that
you've built using primarily wolfram
application server it was really
interesting to see what's possible using
even the lightweight version available
there instead of using the
full functionality of the wolfram cloud
so thanks a lot it's always a pleasure
thanks thanks
that was john mcloone who told us about
using wolfram application server to
build a website
so please stay tuned for more coming
tech talks they'll cover topics ranging
from cryptography to
blockchain to education quite varied if
you're interested in learning more about
using the wolfram language to build and
deploy forms and websites please check
out our free wolfram u courses
i'll see you at the next tech talk
[Music]